I think it comes down to equality which
is I think such a silly thing to say in
2008 but I think it comes down to sort
of civil rights though the right to get
married the right to you know file your
taxes together hospital visitation
rights and and I think beyond that is
equality including in the military with
Don't Ask Don't Tell which seems to
always be a hot-button issue that pops
up you know once a year or so but
especially now with the presidential
debate and candidates taking aside on
the issue and I think it's very clear
that evangelical and very conservative
religious groups maintain quite a bit of
power in this country because there are
you know it's very clear that candidates
are you know are leaning one way or the
other one when it comes to their
approach of them and their viewpoints
have to be taken seriously on the
political spectrum and that's the you
know it's there that these things are
going to change I have a personal issue
with the idea that some people can
tolerate homosexuality I do not tolerate
women I do not tolerate black or Asian
people I embrace them as I would anyone
else and so I think right now we're
sending this message of tolerance and I
think it is a stepping stone toward
embracing or even so much so that it's a
non-issue I think right now that the
goal needs to be to promote this as a
normalized sort of behavior and I think
that if we're taking these sort of
band-aid or sideways approaches to get
to our final result we're going to end
up with something that's still not
viewed very well so the I think the
message we need to be pitching is this
sort of normalized behavior
gay people are just like straight people
they just sleep with the same sex I mean
that's really all it comes down to I
think it's easy for me to say that's
such a simple message not only because I
live in a very urban area but I'm a gay
man you know on the same token I don't
think it's very easy for you know other
folks and more conservative parts of the
country to accept that message I think
one huge mistake the gay community and I
think that the American community as a
whole has made is that HIV is a
treatable disease and thus contracting
it is a non-issue and while that may it
be the case in many hiv-positive people
live long and quote-unquote healthy
lives the cost and trauma to that person
and the family I wouldn't think anybody
would voluntarily want to sign up for I
think there are institutions you know I
I do credit MTV which I have plenty of
problems about but I will you know give
them kudos for raising awareness about
HIV and getting tested
I think the there's a huge part of that
equation missing what do you do when you
get tested it's one thing to walk into a
free clinic and have your blood drawn
it's another thing for you know you to
be told the results that you're positive
and then there are zero marketing
messages about what goes on there and I
think that that's a huge dilemma getting
people tested is the first part beyond
that it's almost as if that that whole
possibility has been ignored
I do think especially in in New York
City that the the use of you know
crystal meth has is resurging among
young people and that leads to plenty of
unprotected sex and I think it is you
know this carefree lifestyle but again I
think it's up to you know each
individual to to really make that call
and to protect themselves but there are
so many industries out there that can
lend a helping hand
inside my bubble the answer to that
question is now in the you know in the
in the rest of America and really the
rest of the world who hasn't really come
to grips that there are gay men and
women walking among them I think it
would be foolish to assume that that
that most people still identify that as
a sort of sect or or a minority
classification I I think it's important
that we get beyond that I don't think we
ever will but but the idea that there is
a gay identity means less to me than a
young person you know then a person my
age probably 20 or 30 years ago thought
where everything in their lives
you know as they were coming out were
hiding their sexuality was built upon
that entire process whereas for me you
know once you once you sort of come out
of the closet and you know share with
other people you know your true self you
move on from that there are things in my
life and people like me who you know
have sort of gay parts of their life in
a sense maybe that determines where we
go out at night but otherwise I think
we're leading the same prosperous lives
as everybody else yes in a sense and in
the same way that I think anybody who's
a member of a certain culture bears that
responsibility because they're a human
being bears that responsibility to
project the best of themselves you know
it's foolish to think that little girls
do not look up to Paris Hilton and it's
foolish to think that young gay men and
women do not look up to adult you know
gay men and women as an example of what
their lives should be leading you know I
I won't I think would be silly to think
you know the the burden falls on every
gay man and woman to carry out that
message but at the same time you know
you you carry so many identities I'm
American I'm Jewish I'm white I'm gay
and and I represent all of those facets
and I hope that when I take myself
abroad or to another state or another
group of friends that I'm representing
the best of of all of those